salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous êtes prêts faites vos jeux rien ne
va
plus si vous avez 18 ans ou plus vous
avez peut-être déjà joué à la roulette
dans un vrai casino avec les machines à
sous et le poker elle fait partie des
jeux les plus populaires de ces
établissements mais savez-vous qui l'a
inventé et comment gagner à tous les
coups ou presque pour le savoir
direction
[Musique]
l'atelier si je vous demande de me citer
une ville qui vous fait penser au casino
il y a de fortes chances que vous me
répondiez Las Vegas c'est la MEC du jeu
cette ville du Nevada en compte aux
alentours de 120 toutefois Vegas comme
on dit n'abrite pas le plus grand casino
du monde il s'agit du vénitiane qui se
trouve à Macao en Chine cet
établissement tenez-vous bien possède
3000 machines à s 870 tables de poker
3000 chambres 24 bars restaurants et une
capacité d'accueil de 15000 personnes la
France n'est pas mal Lottie dans le
genre elle compte 203 casinos exactement
les deux plus célèbres étant ceux de
Douville en Normandie et enen les bain
près de Paris je paris que je vais
encore
perdre encore perdu c'est à Napoléon 1er
que nous devons l'arrivée des premiers
casinos en France au début du 19e siècle
le pays fait face à une grave crise
économique pour renflouer les l'empereur
a alors l'idée en 1806 de créer des
établissements de jeu enin de les
autoriser car ils existent déjà mais
clandestinement il peut ainsi prélever
de lourdes taxes sur les gain ces
casinos sont installés loin des villes
pour des raisons d'éthique à l'époque on
parle plutôt de morale à un moment où la
misère touche une part importante de la
population française Napoléon veut
protéger les plus pauvre en leur évitant
de dilapider leur maigres revenus Paris
gagnant pour l'empereur ses
établissements connaissent un vif succès
mais 30 ans plus tard en
1836 une nouvelle loi interdit purement
et simplement les jeux de hasard sur le
sol français à cause de la morale
justement ils sont accusés de pervertir
la population il faut attendre 1907 pour
qu'il soit à nouveau autorisé à
condition qu'il se situe dans des villes
classées comme station balnéire station
thermale ou station climatique et
uniquement en période de cure mais
pourquoi officiellement l'idée est dans
enrichir ces petites stations qui
commencent à attirer des clients de plus
en plus fortunés officieusement
l'objectif est une nouvelle fois de
désengorger le circuit des jeux
clandestins qui s'évitent à Paris à
cette époque et en 1919 on interdit
carrément l'installation de casino à
moins de 100 km autour de Paris seule
exception enguen les Bains dans le
département du valdoise qui obtient une
dérogation en 1931 des années plus tard
en 1988 la loi permet enfin la création
de casinos dans des villes qui ne sont
pas nécessairement en bord de mer ou
d'un lac à condition qu'ell compte plus
de 500000 habitants et qu'ell soit
classée station touristique c'est pour
cette raison qu'aujourd'hui en France on
trouve des casinos dans des villes comme
Bordeaux Lille ou Lyon et dans 198
autres communes et dans tous ces casinos
on l'a dit l'un des jeux les plus
populaires c'est la roulette rien ne va
plus la règle est assez simple il s'agit
de deviner sur quelle case va s'arrêter
une bille qu'on lance dans le cylindre
de la roulette il y a 36 cases 18 rouges
18 noirs plus une 37e la case 0 qui
n'est ni rouge ni noir vous pouvez miser
soit sur un chiffre 7 8 18 comme vous
voulez sur une couleur rouge ou noire
vous pouvez aussi miser sur la nature
d'un chiffre paire ou Impire ou soit sur
un groupe de chiffres et de nombres de 1
à 18 vous misez sur manque de 19 à 36
vous misez sur passe lorsque le croupier
annonce faites vos jeux vous devez poser
vos jetons autrement dit vos mises sur
les cases de votre choix le 7 par
exemple rouge
manque per vous avez encore le temps de
changer d'avis et de les déplacer
jusqu'à ce qu'il lance rien ne va plus
il jette la bille dans la roulette quand
elle s'arrête la couleur et le numéro
gagnant sont dévoilé et le joueur est
fixé sur son sol côté gain maintenant la
règle est assez simple en fonction du
risque pris par le joueur la récompense
varie par exemple si vous misez sur un
seul chiffre donc une case sur les 37
possibles vous prenez un gros risque
vous emportez 35 fois la mise autrement
dit si vous avez misé 1 € sur le 7 vous
empochchez 35 € à l'inverse si vous
misez sur une couleur noir ou rouge vous
avez une chance sur deux de gagner le
risque est donc plus faible et et le
gain aussi vous doublez votre mise pour
1 € misé sur le rouge si le rouge sort
vous empêchez 2 € mais le hasard est-il
le seul facteur pour gagner et bien pas
forcément alors bien sûr il n'existe
aucune méthode infaillible pour gagner à
tous les coups car vous pensez bien que
si c'était le cas les casinos mettraient
rapidement la clé sous la porte pour
augmenter ses chances de gagner on peut
utiliser les mathématiques des maths
c'est vraiment pas mon jour de chance
rassurez-vous pas besoin d'avoir fait
matsup matp suffit de se concentrer et
de faire fonctionner sa mémoire en
jouant à la roulette si vous pariez sur
un numéro unique la table comportant des
numéros allant de 1 à 36 plus le 0 vous
avez donc 37 résultats possibles dans ce
cas de figure statistiquement vos
chances de l'emporté sont de 2,7 %.
puisque j'exprime les chances de gagner
en pourcentage le calcul est simple il
suffit de diviser 100 par 37 si vous
misez sur deux numéros maintenant vos
chances de l'emporter passe à 5 5,4 % et
ainsi de suite en partant de ce constat
vous pouvez employer des méthodes
simples pour augmenter vos chances de
gagner sans tricher alors il existe
plusieurs techniques je ne vais pas
toutes vous les présenter il faudrait
plusieurs vidéos pour cela nous allons
donc nous concentrer sur celle qui
devrait vous permettre d'augmenter vos
chances de gagner à la roulette elle
découle d'une logique mathématique bien
connue celle d'un mathématicien italien
du 12e siècle Leonardo Fibonacci avant
de commencer une petite précision
cette méthode ne fonctionne que si l'on
mise sur des cases simples paire Impire
rouge noir passe manque ça ne fonctionne
pas lorsque l'on mise sur un
numéro regardez bien ce tableau sur
lequel figure une suite de chiffres et
de nombres apparemment sans rapport les
uns avec les autres pourtant il s'agit
d'une suite logique chaque chiffre
correspond à la somme des deux pré édent
0 + 1 = 1 1 + 1 = 2 1 + 2 = 3 2 + 3 = 5
et cetera et cetera mais quel rapport
avec la roulette imaginez que vous
pariez 1 € sur un numéro paire de
solutions poss possiblebles le numéro
qui tombe et paire vous gagnez il est
Impire vous perdez et bien c'est là que
Fibonacci va nous aider il faut miser en
suivant la suite logique du
mathématicien italien cette suite
commence avec 0 et 1 la première mise
sera donc de 0 + 1 1 €. si vous perdez
la mise suivante sera de 1 + 1 2 €. si
vous perdez à nouveau la mise suivante
est de 1 + 2 3 € et la mise encore
suivante sera de 5 €. si à ce moment-là
vous gagnez et bien vous devez retirer
les deux derniers numéro de la suite à
savoir le 3 et le 2 et reprendre à ce
niveau la mise qui suit sera de 1 + 1 2
€ concrètement la méthode de Fibonacci
demande aux joueurs d'augmenter leur
mise en cas de perte et de diminuer en
cas de gain l'intérêt de cette méthode
c'est de permettre au joueurs de
commencer par de faibles mises et
d'éviter de perdre beaucoup d'argent en
cas de défaite mais je vous le rappelle
la roulette reste avant tout un jeu de
hasard et le seul moyen de gagner à tous
les coups ou presque c'est de tricher ou
de trouver une faille dans les règles du
casino et à ce petit jeux certains ont
réussi un véritable coup de maître il y
a quelques années l'histoire se déroule
en 2004 dans un casino londonien trois
joueurs une femme et deux hommes
bénéficient d'une chance insolente à la
roulette de soir de suite le premier
jour il rafle l'équivalent de 145000 €
avant de faire sauter la banque le
lendemain en empochant 1,7 million
d'euros du jamais vu persuadé qu'ils ont
utiliser une martingale c'est-à-dire une
stratégie qui permet d'augmenter les
chances de gagner les propriétés du
casino porte plainte auprès de
scotlandyard qui place aussitôt les
suspects en détention provisoire les
joueurs sont interrogés et au bout de
quelques heures ils finissent par avouer
oui ils ont triché mais aussi incroyable
que cela puisse paraître ils ne seront
pas condamné par la justice britannique
non mais dis-moi comment ils ont fait en
fait ces petits malins avaient trafiqué
leur téléphone ils analysaient la
vitesse à laquelle la bille était lancée
par le croupier puis il calculaient le
ch sur lequel elle allait s'arrêter avec
une faible marge d'erreur grâce à ce
système ils ont fait passer leur chance
de gagner de une sur 37 à seulement une
sur 6 la prouess c'est d'autant plus
incroyable qu'à cette époque nous sommes
3 ans avant la sortie du tout premier
modèle de smartphone non mais ça se fait
pas c'est de la triche attends
l'histoire n'est pas terminée à l'issu
de 9 mois d'enquête bien que l'arnaque
soit clairement avérée les trois
suspects sont finalement rel accès on va
même leur restituer leur gains en effet
les juges britanniques déclarent que
cette martingale est parfaitement légale
en 2004 la réglementation en vigueur
interdit seulement d'intervenir sur le
fonctionnement physique de l'appareil de
ralentir ou d'accélérer de quelque façon
que ce soit la vitesse de la boule or ce
n'était pas le cas je tiens quand même à
mettre en garde celles et ceux qui
seraient tentés de reproduire la même
chose la législation en vigueur dans
notre pays interdit formellement l'usage
de matériel qui permettrait de remettre
en cause le facteur de hasard dans
l'enceinte des casinos par ailleurs
depuis cette affaire à chaque début de
partie quel que soit le jeu le croupier
demande désormais d'éteindre les
smartphones enfin retenez bien que
tricher au casino peut coûter très cher
en 2018 des petits malins qui avaient
découvert une faille dans les roulettes
électroniques installées en anguien ont
été condamné pour escroquerie en bande
organisé des peines de prison ferme de 3
à 6 mois ont été prononcé ainsi que des
amendes allant jusqu'à 7000 € voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui avant de
vous quitter je tiens quand même à vous
rappeler que le jeu c'est comme l'alcool
la drogue ou le tabac ça peut très vite
devenir addictif alors surtout restez
vigilant si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire
et à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait à très
[Applaudissements]
bientôt